der penetrante Protest Irrsinn der
radikalen Klimaschützer der erreicht
jetzt wirklich ein ganz neuen Höhepunkt
immer wieder schaffen es die
klimaradikalen wertvolle Kunstwerke
Museen zu beschmieren die Frage die sich
stellt ist die Sicherheit zu lasch wie
kommen sie damit durch wir haben den
Test gemacht
Kartoffelbrei für Monet
Tomatensuppe für van Gogh
das gab es vergangene Woche zwei
anti-öl-aktivisten bewerfen das berühmte
Gemälde Sonnenblumen mit zwei Dosen
Tomaten neben der Frage der
Sinnhaftigkeit dieser Aktionen steht vor
allem die Frage im Raum wie diese
Chaoten ihre Behälter mit Wurf Essen in
die Museen schmuggeln können wie leicht
geht das Bild Reporter Victor Wachs
macht den Test
ich habe hier etwas Desinfektionsmittel
und werde jetzt mal probieren damit in
das Barberini Museum in Potsdam zu
kommen in dem gestern der Monet
verunstaltet wurde von den klimakaoten
[Musik]
seine Tasche wird zwar im Eingang des
Museums kontrolliert abgehalten die
Flasche mitzunehmen wird er aber nicht
unbemerkt schlendert er mit der
Flüssigkeit locker flockig durch die
Ausstellung dort hängt auch das Gemälde
von Monet das erneut zu attackieren wäre
ein Leichtes
man sieht also das hat funktioniert
meine Tasche wurde zwar durchleuchtet
aber trotzdem war es kein Problem dieses
Desinfektionsmittel mit reinzunehmen und
der Kunst ganz nah zu kommen die Frage
ist aber sollen Museen wirklich
verpflichtet werden sich wie Festungen
abzuschotten oder wäre es einfach besser
die Kunst gar nicht erst kaputt zu
machen
[Musik]
die 25-Jährige miriam ist keine
Unbekannte im vergangenen Jahr hat sie
sich von einer Autobahnbrücke bei
München abgeseilt aus Protest gegen die
Automesse IAA daraufhin wird sie von der
Staatsanwaltschaft angeklagt jetzt
drohen ihr bis zu vier Jahre Haft wegen
dieser bescheuerten kartoffelbrei-aktion
tja und NDR rundfunkrätin Jessica
kordoni die gibt auch noch Beifall für
diese Sachbeschädigung auf Twitter da
schreibt sie jetzt Monet und van Gogh
hätten diesen Protest gemocht es geht
immerhin um die Schönheit der Welt die
sie gemalt haben und die gerettet werden
muss #kartoffelbrei und #tautomatensuppe
sind absolut Kunst weil sie Absurditäten
aufdecken ja kann man so sehen kann man
aber auch anders sehen absolut wir
sprechen mal über die rechtliche
Komponente bildkonomist und Rechtsanwalt
Joachim Steinhöfel ist zugeschaltet
schönen guten Morgen und sie wissen
natürlich auch was erlaubt ist und was
nicht also die Wut da draußen der Bürger
die wird natürlich irgendwann auch ein
bisschen größer gerade bei den Klima
Klebern im Straßenverkehr wie sieht's
denn aus darf man den Klima Klebern eine
kleben
also ich rate dazu da erstmal etwas
behutsamer vorzugehen aber das was da
geschieht ist auf jeden Fall keine
Lappalie sondern eine
und ein rechtswidriger Eingriff auf die
Bewegungsfreiheit
das Teilnehmer
daher dürfen Sie weil das ein
rechtswidriger Eingriff ist auch zur
Notwehr greifen das ist ein scharfes
Schwert man darf alles tun was dazu
erforderlich ist die Straftat sicher und
endgültig zu beenden das heißt sie gehen
am besten hin fordern die Person auf
sich innerhalb von einer Minute aus der
Strafe von der Straße zu entfernen und
tut sie das nicht dürfen sie alles tun
was erforderlich ist und das zu beenden
ich darf die auch einfach da abreißen
die Hände abreißen und auch wenn die
sich dabei dann ein bisschen weh tun
weil das ist ja mit Sekundenkleber
festgeklebt habe ich damit nichts zu tun
wissen Sie wenn jemand vorgibt die Welt
retten zu wollen sollte er nicht so
dünnhäutig sein dass es ihnen große
etwas ausmacht wenn etwas Haut auf der
Straße kleben bleibt ja das dürfen sie
dann tun wenn der Haut oder leichte
Körperverletzung leichte
Körperverletzung dabei die Folge sind
ist das in Kauf zu nehmen und ohne
weiteres gerechtfertigt Herr Steinhöfel
das waren gekonntes Wortspiel muss man
ihn an der Stelle auch attestieren aber
was passiert denn wenn ich dann wegen
diesem klimaaktivisten einen wichtigen
Termin zum Beispiel verpasse kann ich
diese Klima Extremisten auch haftbar
machen ja sicher das was da geschieht
berechtigt auf jeden Fall die Leute die
einen Schaden erleiden zu
Schadensersatzansprüchen sie dürfen die
Personen sogar festnehmen wenn eine
Straftat begangen wurde und sie der
Polizei übernehmen also wir sind nicht
im Wilden Westen und sie dürfen also die
Leute denen keine Handschellen anlegen
und so weiter aber wenn Sie ein
Straftäter ertappen darf auch ein Bürger
festsetzen um zur Feststellung der
Personalien der Polizei übergeben das
ist erlaubt Schadensersatz müssen diese
Leute auch bezahlen also wenn Sie
irgendeinen Schaden haben Verspätung du
verpasst dann müssen die bezahlen wird
da auch noch mal unterschieden zwischen
Minderjährigen und nicht Minderjährigen
Aktivisten ja es gibt ja das
Jugendstrafrecht und das sieht mindere
Strafen vor das kennt man ja sonst
normalerweise nur aus der organisierten
Kriminalität und bei Drogen eingesetzt
werden ich glaube hier sind sie zwar
vielleicht intellektuell minderjährig
aber vom Alter her sind sie glaube ich
alle volljährig jetzt haben wir gerade
noch im Beitrag besagte Miriam gesehen
die ist ja nun auch eigentlich Jura
Studentin zumindest hat sie eine ganze
Weile Jura studiert wenn Sie sich jetzt
irgendwann noch mal umentscheiden würde
und sagt ich bin jetzt nicht mehr
Vollzeit klimaaktivistin sondern ich
möchte meinen Beruf noch mal ausüben
wenn sie vorbestraft ist wenn sie jetzt
tatsächlich sogar eine Haftstrafe
absetzen muss könnte das schwierig
werden oder
ja gut dann ist die Eignung dazu ein man
ist ja normalerweise zum Richteramt
befähigt wenn man das Studium
abgeschlossen hat ein vorbestraft der
darf das in der Regel nicht mehr werden
die genauen Details kenne ich da nicht
aber wenn sie fünf Jahre im Gefängnis
gesetzt haben wegen schwerer
Körperverletzung können sie nicht ein
Jahr später auf der Richterbank sitzen
oder Anwalt sein das ist schon klar
empfehlen die charakterliche fachliche
und sicherlich auch intellektuelle
Geeignetheit für diesen Beruf ja im
Steinhöfel ganz klare Worte danke schön
so wir begrüßen jetzt und sprechen mit
Bild Chefreporter Peter Tide bei uns im
Studio wir haben ja gerade auch schon
diverse klare Kanten gehört die kriegen
wir wahrscheinlich jetzt auch von deiner
Seite du sagst was sie nicht verdienen
ist Aufmerksamkeit dennoch müssen wir
natürlich drüber reden oder was wir da
die optimale Lösung an deiner Stelle um
dem Ganzen mal ein Ende zu setzen also
wenn eine bestimmte Gruppe für sich in
Anspruch nimmt einfach die öffentliche
Ordnung und Sicherheit gefährden zu
können in den Straßenverkehr eingreifen
zu können und sich herausnimmt im Museen
reinzugehen und Kunstwerke mit die
schönsten Sachen die Menschen Hände je
erschaffen haben einfach zu schenken
dann muss man darüber reden wo wir nicht
reden müssen sind die vorgeschobenen
Gründe das sind im Prinzip wie
vieljährige Rotzlöffel die sich am
Supermarktregal den Schokoriegeln auf
die Erde schmeißen und Trommeln und
Aufmerksamkeit haben wollen jeder
vernünftige Elternteil lässt sie da
liegen solange es und wie geht die
beruhigen sich wieder die müssen
runterkommen und wir können nicht
ernsthaft sagen dass wir die in eine
Diskussion über Klima und Umweltschutz
reinnehmen das wäre als würden wir mit
dem flaschend die
Eigentumsfrage neu definieren wollen
also würden wir mit dem verkehrsraudi
die Straßenverkehrsordnung neu
auswandern wollen nein mit kriminellen
diskutiert man nicht in der Sache die
gehören vor Gericht die gehören zur zur
Polizei und und auch in
Untersuchungshaft wenn es sein muss naja
das Argument dass sie haben das ist ja
wir haben sehr lange probiert wir haben
ja versucht friedlich zu protestieren
wir haben versucht zu demonstrieren aber
keiner hat uns gehört und die Sache ist
und so wichtig da müssen wir jetzt eben
einfach mal Aufmerksamkeit generieren
und man muss sagen durch diese Aktion
Aufmerksamkeit bekommen sie ja sollte
man dann einfach die mediale
Aufmerksamkeit einschränken aber nicht
aber sie nicht Aktivisten denn sie sind
keine Aktivisten demnächst Rente
Handtaschen die durch die Fußgängerzone
klaut den Omas die Handtasche und
schiebten politischen Grundform schon
gehen wir nicht mehr darüber dass ein
Straftäter ist sondern darüber dass er
die Handtasche für den Umweltschutz oder
als Robin Hood geklaut hat nein die
beginnt Straftaten und wir leben in
einer Demokratie da gibt es bestimmte
Regeln an die wir uns halten wir leben
nicht in der Steinzeit wo wir mit der
Keule rumlaufen und jeder eigenes
Interesse für seinen partikular
Interesse nicht mehr demokratisch
kämpfen muss sondern mit der Keule in
der Fußgängerzone steht so geht's nicht
in diesem Ton hast du Angst dass die
sich auch wirklich noch weiter
radikalisieren könnten bislang sind auch
keine Menschen zu Schaden gekommen
bislang geht es nur um Kunstwerke und
auch die waren bislang mit glasschutz ne
es gab Unfälle bei da haben sich welche
von der Autobahnbrücke abgesagt hinten
gab es entstanden da gab es einen Opfer
Unfall natürlich sind der Menschen schon
zu stark schon zu Schaden gekommen es
gab noch keine Todesopfer und es ist
nicht das erste Mal dass ich in der
deutschen Geschichte eine Minderheit
darin irrt zu meinen sie habe das Recht
gepachtet wir streiten in einer
Demokratie miteinander wir kämpfen
miteinander mit Worten mit Argumenten
aber nicht mit Straftaten das kann man
nicht durchgehen lassen und wenn ich
dann Politiker höre die dem auch noch
Beifalls sollen oder Promis wie Frau
Neubauer die die Kunst vorschieben
herrgott nochmal kunstständen hat mit
Kunst nicht zu tun sich an einem
Kunstwerk Vergehen ist keine Kunst das
ist eine Straftat das ist ein
Eigentumsdelikt und wir müssen mal
aufhören jeden der nur weil er
vermeintlich gute Gründe hat wirklich
auch anzuhören wer brüllt hat Unrecht
absurd ist es auf jeden Fall dass sie
dann auch noch Fürsprecher finden
tatsächlich kannst du sagen dass es sich
hier auch um eine Art Doppelmoral
handelt also glaubst es geht ihnen
wirklich nur um die Sache oder es geht
ihnen auch darum Aufmerksamkeit zu
generieren abschließend dazu noch also
ich spreche Ihnen nicht ab dass sie
ursprünglich tatsächlich Aufmerksamkeit
auf eine bestimmte Sachen denken wollen
aber es ist immer die Frage der Wahl der
Mittel und da hat man die auch und wer
sich jetzt so radikalisiert der ist
tatsächlich in Einzelfällen auch nicht
mehr weiter davon wirklich in den Terror
abzuleiten und natürlich gibt es eine
Doppelmoral gucken jetzt mal Miriam an
die 25-Jährige vollzeitaktivist sind
jetzt in Leipzig lieb vor das Passau kam
und dann nicht mehr studiert die ist
durch die ganze Welt gilt die waren
Tansania und und und wie sonst wo und
uns will die belehren über Umweltschutz
dann soll sie erstmal nicht mehr fliegen
das so funktioniert sie und das ist eine
doppelmoralis ist auch eine Doppelmoral
von denjenigen von den prominenten von
diesen von diesen Twitter Promis die
sich auf die berufen und Dinge zur Seite
springen
ganz klare Meinung zu den Klima Klebern
danke schön
[Musik]